this episode is brought to you by nebula
and kind of me
I want to ask you what is the number one
reduce carbon
you might say you
or veganism or solar power or not flying
the problem with comparing these and
trying to find the best is that there is
no one method for calculating carbon
emissions Productions that work is done
by research groups all over the world
independently using different methods or
at least that was the case until project
drawdown which I've mentioned before on
the channel in 2017 they published a
book called drawdown which ranks
solutions to climate change based on the
reductions in emissions those solutions
would create by the year 2050. the
book's top five list looks like this at
number five it's restoring tropical
forests at number four promoting a
plant-rich diet at number three reducing
food waste at number two it's using
onshore power and Topping the charts at
number one it's
Refrigeration basically if people all
over the world open their fridges then
the planet on average is inside a fridge
and so we'll call that no it's it's
don't actually do do that it all has to
do with how fridges work a fridge is
basically a box that you keep cold by
pumping very cold refrigerant through a
long pipe inside the box that
refrigerant is a chemical in a closed
Plumbing Loop where it goes from high
pressure to low pressure turn from the
vapor into a liquid and then evaporates
into a vapor again it's a complicated
process that you don't need to
understand you just need to know that
you can't use any old chemical as your
refrigerant it has to be a specific kind
with some specific properties the family
of chemicals most fridges use for their
refrigerants are hfcs or
hydrofluorocarbons which because of
their properties are very good at being
refrigerants but they're also some of
the most powerful greenhouse gases known
to mankind how powerful we define global
warming potential by the amount of
warming a gas causes in the atmosphere
over a hundred years compared to carbon
dioxide so CO2 has a warming potential
of one methane has a warming potential
of 25 30 the hfcs have warming
Potentials in the thousands hfc 23 has a
global warming potential of as much as
14 800 which is a problem because hfcs
do leak to the atmosphere at every stage
in their life cycle when you produce
them when you install them in
refrigeration units and most importantly
when you dispose of refrigeration units
at the end of their life hfcs are a
significant source of carbon emissions
so why are we using hfcs well originally
the family of chemicals we used were
chlorofluorocarbons or CFCs which you
may have heard of before as being
responsible for destroying the ozone
layer we don't have the best track
record on refrigerants recognizing this
problem the UN agreed the Montreal
protocol in 1987 which phased out the
use of CFCs and has been maybe the most
successful International agreement ever
I did a whole video on how it
deliberately and accidentally avoided a
nightmare future however we replaced
CFCs with hfcs and so swapped the ozone
depletion problem for a carbon emissions
problem so in 2016 an amendment was
passed to the Montreal protocol called
the Kigali Amendment which forces
countries to phase out the use
manufacture and import of hfc gases at
the time of recording 150 States
including the EU us China and India have
signed up to the amendment and as far as
we can tell it seems to be working it's
not enough to just phase out the
manufacture and use of hfcs we need to
destroy via a thermal oxidation process
the refrigerants that are currently in
use when a refrigeration unit comes to
the end of its life and that's something
which we can do right now and is not too
expensive and this is what drawdown
estimates is the number one way we can
reduce our carbon emissions drawdown
estimates that 87 of hfcs used as a
refrigerator can be collected and
destroyed rather than being vented to
the atmosphere and doing so by 2050
would prevent the equivalent of 89.7
gigatons of CO2 being emitted note that
the actual tonnage of emissions of hfcs
would be much lower it's just that hfcs
are so much more potent than CO2 on top
of that if the Kigali amendment is
implemented as planned that would
prevent the equivalent of up to 78
gigatons of CO2 being emitted so by
phasing out and destroying hfcs that's a
colossal
167.7 gigatons of carbon dioxide
equivalent not being emitted to the
atmosphere almost double the impact of
rolling out onshore wind equivalent to
four and a half years of current
emissions just from fridges I love
refrigerators except it's not just from
fridges and this is where things get a
bit more interesting because where else
do we use referred duration units air
conditioners functionally they're
fridges with fans as the planet warms
and in particular we see more and more
extreme heat events the demand for air
conditioning is going to grow especially
in places where the middle class is
growing such as Asia the Middle East and
Africa places that for the most part
have contributed the least to climate
change and yet are expected to Bear the
brunt of increased heat stress so it's
vital that we phase out the use of hfcs
and start using Alternatives now before
that boom happens fortunately there are
lots of Alternatives already in use
notably refrigerant r290 better known as
propane
some Alternatives including propane are
flammable which is a risk but they're
used in very small quantities in these
units and have been used in heat pumps
without incidents if you'd like a long
list of alternative refrigerants then
Greenpeace has this very long document
you can check out when considering any
proposed action to reduce carbon
emissions from a thing humans do you
have to consider two factors firstly how
large current emissions from that thing
are and so the maximum possible savings
and secondly how easily with current or
near future Tech those savings can be
achieved Refrigeration is a winner on
both counts a huge source of emissions
that you likely weren't aware of before
you watch this video but also a source
of emissions that we can remove almost
entirely thanks to many Alternatives
being available in this case the action
is simple phase out the use of hfcs
which we're doing and ensure that
refrigerants are destroyed rather than
emitted to the atmosphere when a
refrigeration unit comes to the end of
its life both of these are only possible
with legislation they are two actions
that you wouldn't do unless you had some
government policy telling you you need
to do them coordinated climate policy is
the way we're going to get out of this
mess and sometimes it's going to involve
legislating things that may seem too
small to make a significant impact but
don't be deceived replacing refrigerants
is a significant and easy win in
reducing our carbon emissions but as
drawdown demonstrates it's just one of a
vast array of solutions necessary to
bring our emissions down to zero there
is no Silver Bullet when it comes to
climate change
but there is silver Buckshot and as the
Montreal protocol demonstrated targeted
International legislation works if we
break the problem down and attack it
piece by piece sector by sector we can
do this and some solutions may surprise
you such as a law that replaces the
fluid
in your fridge
I hope that you came away from this
video informed about hfcs aware of the
Kigali Amendment and understanding that
the solution to climate change is
Buckshot not bullet you may have noticed
by the way that this video is in an ABA
format which is aimed at a younger
audience with moderate science Capital
this right here is how I Define what
video I'm going to make before I write a
script over the many years I've done
this job I have built up a personal
method of how I make videos which is a
little different to how other science
channels operate if you like my videos
and you'd like to learn how to make
videos like them yourself then you
should consider checking out my seven
part course on how to turn data into
stories available right now on nebula
classes accessible to everyone who has
nebula in the class you'll learn about
how I Define a video you'll learn how I
frame scientific ideas in a storytelling
format I go into detail about how I
structure my videos and talk about how I
design and include figures and data
visualizations throughout the class
you'll see me conceptualize structure
and write a video on the Antarctic
impossibility of 2002 which when you're
finished with the class you can watch as
a finished video exclusively on nebula
this is the first time I've put all this
stuff together in a class and I'm really
proud of it and it's just one of many
classes available on nebula if you'd
like to learn more about the Practical
side of making videos then you could
check out Patrick H Williams or Renny
Ritchie or you could learn about
something entirely different like
business 101 or how to produce a pop
song If you're not aware nebula is the
streaming service co-owned and operated
by a whole bunch of educational
YouTubers including me where over 600
000 subscribers enjoy ad-free content
before it's available on YouTube and
enjoy exclusive nebula Originals such as
real-time histories series on the Soviet
nuclear program as well of course as all
the classes I mentioned you can get
access to nebula with a subscription
which could be monthly or annual and if
you use my link which will be linked
down there go.nebula.tv Simon Clark you
get 40 off an annual subscription which
works out to be about 2.50 a month and
for that not only do you get access to
all this incredible stuff you also
directly support the creators that you
watch on nebula I really hope that you
do check out my course I think it's very
good and I think it can teach you a lot
about science Communication in general
and how to make YouTube videos
specifically that link again was
go.nebula.tv Simon Clark for 40 off a
subscription with thanks to nebula and
me for sponsoring this video thank you
so much for watching the video this was
a video topic that with a little bit of
backstory my patrons chose for me if you
would like to choose a video topic for
me to cover a month get access to behind
the scenes Vlogs and directly support me
making more videos then please do
consider checking out my patreon the
name's on screen right now are my lovely
executive producer patrons if you
learned something from this video tell
you what pay it forwards pop this video
in a group chat or a Discord or a
subreddit or wherever and if you enjoyed
the video please do also pop it a like
that just leads me to say thank you very
much again for watching I'll see you in
the next one